resisted motion is also called motion
through a medium
this is really interesting because
when we had a look through
projectile motion sometimes you may
recall questions specifically said
ignoring air resistance blah blah blah
blah so we had this a look at this very
specialized um idealized situation but
now we're saying you know what the
meaning you're traveling through
sometimes it has an enormous effect on
your motion sometimes it's the main
thing in the motion that's affecting you
okay it's the main force that's
interacting with you so i have three
introductory tips to start us off and
then we're going to look at um two
examples
that are going to demonstrate that okay
and they're quite a long example so stay
with me
first introductory chip calling you back
to likely the first two calling back to
things you remember yesterday i want you
to remember
our crucial
force relationship right our equation
that we start most of our questions with
the imps that demonstrate okay what are
the forces and where do they come from
what's the equation again f equals
okay very good so remember this
just like before
hey aaron do you wanna thanks ginty
let's go
just like before
these are just a specific kind of motion
so it's not like different rules applied
mostly i'm gonna start with the same
starting point okay
secondly because of what's going on with
you know
this kind of thing slowing you down and
other things speeding you up etc uh one
of the most important
ideas that you'll encounter repeatedly
is terminal velocity okay now this idea
of terminal velocity
is this idea of a limit right
as time progresses if you fall from a
great height or you're going around
something with a great distance and lots
of time can pass before you say collide
with something then you're going to hit
a velocity right you're either going to
slow down a speed up and reach a certain
velocity and then that's that's the
limit it's like a limiting sum for a gp
okay now i want you to think about
newton's laws
three of them right and which one of
them describes what's going on with
terminal velocity now bit of a clue i've
already used one of the laws to tell you
f equals ma so which of those do you
think
is most closely related to terminal
velocity
first one now why you weren't the only
one who said it why is it that the first
law which is that inertia and that i
mean why does that describe this did you
take this
because yeah brendan um it gets to a
point where the force is acting on the
balance out so it stays at a velocity
yeah fantastic another way of saying
this i'd love you to write this movie is
the terminal velocity essentially is
uniform straight line
you're moving in a straight line you're
not speeding up you're not slowing down
and we know that if you're moving in a
uniform straight line just as brendan
said you've got your forces balancing
out so net force is zero and that's what
the first law is about okay
so both of these things are kind of
things from yesterday even though we
didn't specifically mention this example
this last item is in some ways it's the
most confusing um but it's also the most
practically important for solving these
questions
when you've got an object it's moving
left or right it's moving up or down
okay when you're dealing with resistant
motion you must must define
the positive direction
as the direction of motion okay let me
say that again you've got to define
positive
as the direction of motion so for
instance if you have
an object that you throw up into the air
then you've got to define positive as up
if it's projected okay if you've got an
object and it's falling through the air
then you've got to define down as
positive because that's the direction
that you're going in okay if you've got
an object and it goes up
and then it comes down you need to stop
halfway through and redefine what
positive is you do half the question
with positive is up then you say okay
new origin new starting point new
initial conditions and then i have a new
thing going down okay
now the reason why um
there's a whole variety of reasons um i
don't know how much you need to satisfy
yourself of like
why does it matter like earlier on it
didn't matter which way you defined as
positive okay you can define this is
positive or that is positive and all
your negatives will sort of come out in
the wash
the main reason why it's such a big deal
with resisted motion okay is that
whichever direction you're moving in
the whole idea of resistance is that
it's opposing whatever direction you're
traveling okay now if you go backwards
and forwards your signs are all going to
get mixed up when you integrate that's
going to cause you huge problems you
just would be able to solve the question
and i will demonstrate that for you
shortly okay so remember this is still
generally your starting point
when they talk about terminal velocity
which they will a lot
that means net force is zero
and lastly just be super super careful
you can't be arbitrary define positive
make a statement based on whatever's
happening in your question and if
required redefine what positive is if
there's like a turning point or
something like that well a diagram call
it
will the diagram cut it
we are obviously going to do a whole
bunch of diagrams i think you're crazy
not to do a diagram i don't think it's
sufficient i think it's sufficient
because often you use a single diagram
to represent a situation where there's a
change in direction and it's like what
are you going to do you're going to have
a diagram like this and for the first
half of the question you're like there's
positive and then as you're like oh i
reached a point where i had to go down
so then you're like okay now this is
positive is that confusing or what so
you should have a diagram i'm quite
happy with you to do something like this
um but i think you should tell me what
you do here okay it marks enough of a
gear change in the question that you
should say something about